newly released court documents reveal
how the Special Counsel closed in on
former Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort and his associate Rick gates
the two men are expected to appear
tomorrow in federal court Paula Reid is
outside the court in Washington with new
evidence in the Russia investigation
Paula good morning good morning
both men are currently under house
arrest which is a pretty unusual
arrangement for white-collar crimes but
this morning we're learning new details
about why the Special Counsel is
demanding extreme measures in the 17
page memorandum prosecutors say men
affort and gates pose serious flight
risks citing their history of deceptive
and misleading conduct the special
counsel says earlier this year mana Ford
registered a phone and email under an
alias and then traveled to Mexico China
and Ecuador according to the document
man affort has three US passports with
different numbers
Andrew Weissman who argued for the house
arrest is known for flipping witnesses
in high-profile cases in another
document now unsealed a judge says that
one of mana Ford's former lawyers could
be called to testify making an unusual
exception to attorney-client privilege
made in cases where clients may have
lied to their lawyers and investigators
are still interested in the June 2016
meeting at Trump Tower that mana fort
attended along with Donald Trump jr. and
a Russian lawyer to discuss potentially
damaging information on Hillary Clinton
while president Trump tried to distance
himself from the mauler indictments the
special counsel will be talking to
current members of the West Wing and
will interview one official this week
and more after the president's trip to
Asia including White House
communications director hope Hicks
Muller's grand jury will also be here at
the federal courthouse on Thursday to
hear more evidence in the case
CBS News has learned there are other
documents under seal but it is not known
who if anyone will be publicly charged
gale all right Thank You Paula